we're doing golfers now BMXers so I'm
just trying to Branch out it's a new
year
[Music]
what's up everybody I'm Jeffree Star and
I'm here to answer the internet how many
dicks have you saw
just awesome
what has been your most expensive meal
oh wow that's a good one oh I know
actually so my most expensive meal uh
for my ex I rented out a private island
in in the French Polynesia Bora Bora and
I had the locals cook exclusively for us
God damn and do a five course meal so I
think that was like I don't know like
maybe a little casual 50 000 for a meal
eat every bite what was that for
anniversary anniversary oh my God damn
I'm now single
which celebrity would you most want to
see in a sex tape oh wow I'm gonna go
with my gut immediately wants to see
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky once that second
baby's born they'll want to see
you would you rather dress like
a Karen mom or a nerdy dad well I've
been tapping into my masculine side
lately so I would definitely be the dad
and what are we thinking like New
Balance sneakers big baggy jeans I think
what would be your look I would want to
do I'm already a Rancher so I want to do
I want to do the full golf aesthetic
okay I want to be golf Dad wow who is
the number one person you'd want
promoting Cotton Candy Queen collection
and who is the last
so we do have a new makeup collection
coming out
um and I mean I think I do a pretty
great job promoting it but there is a
lot of new influencers and my favorite
is Miss Meredith she's the queen of tech
talk and I love her and I think the last
sadly I love you Michaela but we don't
do Liars in this house if you could get
access to one person's phone and look at
all their who would it be oh wow
we all want to see it I want to
see Trump's phone that's the number one
everybody everybody care about
celebrities I have the same dick sucking
on my phone
would you watch a sex tape of your
number one celebrity banging your arch
enemy absolutely I love warriorism I'm
down to watch anyone I don't care
if I hate you but if I want to see what
you're working with it's numb if it's
your true Arch Enemy that person like
makes you sick you know and then you got
to watch them like the girl or guy
or your dreams I'm down to vomit
if you could live inside of one TV show
what would you live in oh I just want to
be uh Peggy Bundy
that show completely flipped the male
female Dynamic on his head she wanted to
all the time he was like no no no
yeah and that was early for them it was
awesome so what was the show called uh
Married with Children Married with
Children duh let's go so I would
definitely want to be in there Cali
Bundy was so hot she was so hot what do
you think is the oldest someone's been
when they've had sex so meaning like the
oldest person to ever have sex basically
okay I was like yeah it's not worth it
well we just saw the 106 year old lady
on the cover of Vogue fully tattooed
yeah yeah so you think she was still
absolutely would you rather only
to be able to wear ugly shoes or ugly
underwear for the rest of your life
we're gonna stick with hot shoes and I'm
just not gonna wear any underwear
loophole that's a loophole I
prefer glory holes oh you know what's
funny here you go I got something for
everything it's the address
okay if you came across a glory hole I'm
dead would you put your dick in
it I'm pretty sure I would be on my
knees with my custom Gucci knee pads
what is one thing that someone can say
that makes you immediately hate them oh
God there's so many I was gonna say so
many can you narrow down to just one
it's really hard to narrow it down I
just hate everyone I think I'm triggered
because recently I wanted to hang out
with someone and uh they didn't have any
gas money next we're not broke
people in 2023 this year
NBA or NFL oh I've honestly had a lot
more fun with the NFL over the last two
years thank you pandemic a lot of Borden
horny men found me
if you can have one person narrate or do
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be
actually uh my hair stylist who makes
all my wigs he's here today Jay I would
definitely have him in there great
because of the voice because he has his
amazing accent he's he's bilingual
bisexual are you down you're good oh I
love a good POV
okay that's a good way to go I got one
for that too
um if you had to watch one category of
porn for the rest of your life what
would it be I don't even have to
hesitate gangbang
me too yeah see we've all got that in
common yeah right
it's a guy thing
what's Your Number One karaoke song okay
so this is me this is a secret fact I
have never done karaoke I it's my number
and I refuse to in my life but if I had
to I would do Spice Girls Wannabe good
great choice why have you never done it
before I just don't I perform every day
for a living I ain't going out there
Merry or kill
oh Lord we're going to marry Italian
food and those Italian stallions dear
God we're going to Mexican food
Mexican food is the best and then we're
gonna kill Chinese food not for me I
just love cheeseburgers and I like I'm
so simple I'll take this pasta how much
would you have to have to make to make
an only fans so we got an offer I was
entertaining it and I made some content
and then I never move forward so I'm
I've made enough money on my own so I
don't think there's a number I just
think everybody's got a number when you
have when you have it all you don't if I
said you could get a billion dollars
right now you're not doing a billion I
can't spend what I have now
yo hook your boy up come on spread it
around are you home huh
is that I said are you hung
um I don't think I would be described as
hung yeah I would be too short for me
too short if you're not yeah how what's
the cut off
cut off is anything past this
head
I prefer like six six seven eight nine
six seven eight nine God what is this oh
this is a three-parter my first tattoo
it's actually on my ankle and if these
shoes weren't atrocious to take off I
would show you and it was my first one I
was just trying to make my mom proud and
it's the word on my ankle yo you
dove in right away head first and I let
my mom know I'm boss
um yeah that was my nickname it was my
like it was my MySpace name it was very
offensive on purpose and it was just
about getting attention I was 18 years
old and I still have it and you regret
it's funny but some people when they
photograph me do Photoshop it out
because it's too offensive oh that
them all right number two my
favorite tattoo oh that's a hard one
I have about a hundred I think my
Knuckles they say this is my grandma's
nickname when I was little she called me
her cat's meow oh that's cute so I got
that on my hand so I think that one is
there anywhere on your body's not tanked
up my tank hey yeah are you gonna ever
do that oh I don't know I haven't fallen
in love with the person we're gonna put
their name on you that's the final thing
what do you want to be your last tattoo
oh I do have a few spots one lower back
um and then maybe an ass cheek so I
don't know I'm a Rancher now so I want
to get a portrait of a yak
maybe a yak on your taint yeah yeah not
much room what's the biggest Flex having
a custom designer gun or a custom
designer sex toy I think a gun because
yeah so Beretta made me two Custom Guns
um a pistol and a c4x submachine gun CX4
sorry they'll jump down your throat for
that and yeah I and makeup brought us
together which is cool the owner of
Beretta his girlfriend likes my brand
and we all met in Italy and we've
created this amazing Masterpiece gun I
think a lot of porn stars have custom
sex toys it's their dick I'd rather have
the real thing who is the one person in
the world you would at least want to
bang your significant other
uh what's your answer go
that's what I care about anyone
really yeah I think five years ago I may
have had an answer who would have been
all right we found the line would you
rather have one giant dick for an arm or
have all fingers be dicks Cannon for an
arm
um I think I'm gonna go with multiple
you want I I knew that was so many just
as many dicks as you could possibly get
if you could get faced with any U.S
president who would it be no you don't
drink but you know smoke a blunt with
her I would really love just smoke a fat
blot with Obama yeah it would be I mean
there's Obama kush now and you know the
smoking dope right now
absolutely he was the whole time come on
I don't blame him what's one rumor you'd
want to spread about yourself oh you
could convince the whole world of
something about you or it could be true
too if you would just want what's
something you want the world to believe
or to know about pregnant
I'm caring right now to another married
kill oh my God
um okay this is genius so we're gonna my
mystery NFL boy Will Compton or Taylor
Lee won I think oh dear God I think
we're gonna marry the mystery NFL boy
okay he makes uh more money than those
two
um and I definitely Taylor and
Will's definitely getting assassinated
you really it's crazy how much you have
like the whole NFL World it actually
opened the doors to a few more people
reaching out did it really thank you so
much how many what's the roster at right
now NFL wise oh God we're doing golfers
now BMXers so I'm just trying to Branch
out it's a new year
we're trying different sports
you're watching answer the internet
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out